joining us now Texas senator Ted Cruz by
the way oh what a beatdown a poor Chucky
this weekend you it was like on where it
was like here
he's like hit him down pull him up again
hit him again
pull him up boom great job all right wow
that was fun this is serious stuff yeah
we got a dirty dossier paid for by
Hillary Clinton yeah everyone seems to
care about Russian interference but not
that now you read this report today and
you hear the comments of both Durham and
bar your reaction well today is both
chilling and encouraging it's chilling
reading the Inspector General report it
is stunning the abuse of power that we
saw in the Obama administration and
sadly it continued over in the deep
state for the first couple of years the
Trump administration you saw the abuse
of power at the FBI the abuse of power
at the Department of Justice and and I
got to say as an alumnus of the
Department of Justice I'm angry I think
there are a lot of good men and women
that serve at the Department of Justice
and the FBI who were angry reading this
report the very best interpretation of
the horowitz Inspector General report is
that the FBI and Department of Justice
were manifestly incompetent that the IG
report outlines 17 factual Mis
statements that they made to the FISA
Court and that and that they were
utterly negligent in in ordering the
surveillance the spying of a
presidential nominee and of a sitting
president that's the most favorable
interpretation the real interpretation
is these were hard core political
partisans that hated Donald Trump and
they were willing and complicit to abuse
the power of law enforcement and
intelligence and spy on a political
opponent I think that's very civil
liberties and constitutional rights
something we both care deeply about
every American should care deeply about
where do you see this now headed because
well and and that's the second piece and
why it's encouraging I think this I GE
report is the first step in the
wrongdoers being held accountable I was
very encouraged by both by attorney
general Barr statement and US Attorney
Durham's statement that more
accountability will come and I hope that
those who abused power will be held to
account but I'll tell you why
also encouraged because the entire
Democratic show trial at the house is
collapsing we're seeing the media
panicky you know you talked about Chuck
Todd yesterday that the media is is on
full-on panic because what they hoped
this impeachment trial would prove
hasn't been proving and it's like rats
fleeing a sinking ship the house I
assume is gonna have a partisan vote
next week to impeach but it's going to
the Senate and it's not going anywhere
in the Senate we're gonna throw it out
and reject it because it is based on no
facts and no evidence all right senator
could good to see you thank you great
job with Chucky the other day